yeah welcome to a new 15 minute game you
play deform and turn I'll play the
Sicilian for a change and neither three
so what line ok I'll try for for the
night off and yeah we actually get one I
think so let's see what variation is
going for Bishop g5 them yeah the old
main line and down the sharpest muth
yeah yeah black gum recently in fact
them experimented with quite a number of
moves even the old move from night b37
gained some popularity ok let's let's
play this I don't know I'm the theory
anyway
um yeah wyd some old choice yeah i think
which even know was tested in a famous
game spassky versus petrosyan Petrosian
playing this line with black I'm in a
watch championship measures Bishop c4
Spassky played Bishop c4 I think I'm
something like taking on f6 and a quick
lon casler followed yeah so Bishop c4 is
one movie had f-4s also move exactly
what now I think it is even possible to
to play a queen bee 6 here is it has
been played okay I try this attacking
the beach upon at some similar of course
to the poisoned pawn just that I've
played night be 27 and set of e6 so wyd
some principle choice you would be to
play 22 obviously just sacrificing the
beat upon
okay so this is some the conservative
choice so what should I do now in numb
in the other position would be six I
think black just um develops here I
could I could think about h6 reading it
is an idea if he plays Bishop h4 I can
play Queen to III actually winning upon
which might be risky but porn is porn
okay let's try this if he takes on f6 I
can recapture with an ID and this is a
really difference to the position with
e6 well on age six some young white
could just capture okay so he took
really should I actually give the check
now only three is this some is this a
good idea is it simply simply bogus I
think it would play out there should be
two and then Knight f6 mmm you have the
queen is some a bit of an annoying p
some on only three okay so I'm I'll play
this check and see how what happens
maybe he will even chicken out with
Queenie to after which I would just have
fun a good end again game or let's say
middle again without Queens with the two
bishops
okay the only thing of course is my
development isn't isn't so great so what
should I do now of course I would like
to take with the knight on f6 but then
II five for Sam may be a bit of a
problem if I followed by 95 and my bad
development really am yeah Willem is a
problem okay so let's take with the porn
it's not a big deal this double porn
yeah okay now he threatens this this
check obviously so I need to attend to
this should I just play rugby eight yeah
I guess so if you give the check now I
just have Kim v8 and next move I'll play
you six that kick the night away okay so
maybe he's got 92 III and then lie to
see for this some actually could be an
idea
yeah well I need to get rid of this
piece yeah 93 that seems better to me
than Knight to c3 so maybe be five now
preventing the scene I guess so need to
prevent Nazi form and of course be five
also allows to play Bishop e7 probably
next move for in the very near future
yeah the moment of this position doesn't
look so terrible for white but in the
long run it can be a tricky to play
against the bishops so tacky for and
cover the c6 square um actually how does
he defend it we should have three a
plane night to see five maybe and isn't
the pawn almost gone yeah maybe he can
go F 595 f5 p.m. this could could be in
a could be a problem and it still as a
pawn okay let's attack the e4 pawn
and maybe can go on IG fire plate this
bit too quickly hmm Nyjah form attacking
f-16 enter preparing to earn to cover
the pawn rook e1 on 92 yeah not chief I
needs to play maybe maybe I'll night
before I could consider age 5 h 5 and if
he takes on f6 king e7 but it's got a 5
p.m. does sound the problem
hmm yeah so why should i go to e7 or two
to g7 sg7 any I kind of idea with f5
maybe coming don't think so I want to
cover or keep d6 covered yeah very
quickly played yeah still what what is
happening here if I take take on e5 and
play f5 I'm sorry yeah yeah now should I
go f5 or should I take f5 I think it's
more interesting if I've could could
really be a weakness here yeah for sorry
for the bottle noises I need some water
we cannot play you have an hour game
without earn at least down and up at
least a big glass of water so what
should he play now the night is sane and
um yeah it doesn't have really am great
great squares
yeah d5 pawn that's really them the
point I'd like to attack but what's
happening on the Sun long diagonal maybe
96 is also an option which could could
irritate me what moves are down mmm one
idea is to to play very directly just
Bishop g5 check and then Bishop
somewhere to e 30 to a form yeah this is
indeed very am a very direct way it's
maybe not bad even some capitals looks
like an active post for the bishop so
Bishop e3 this this sum is an idea or
Bishop f4 attacking attacking the porn
very young directly played
okay if he plays a move like Knight to
c6 i think i can just play rook c8 and
not much is happening I'm not sure I
want to take it if he plays 96 I could I
could do it it's not so bad yeah well
one point of this this some Bishop move
has to yeah actually I wanted to say
that he cannot play this because I just
take age too but then it's there some
reason why I shouldn't take h2m don't
know 92 something like this no i have
ninety-seven okay let's take it I think
he just so I don't know gave it away
don't see the big the big pointy m-maybe
take our takes that night at three f5
Bishop g3 I just threaten Bishop d3 also
with this the spinner coming
yeah well so yeah it's just upon what
can you do okay if I take with them the
rook now I must be careful about this
Nazi 696 would just threaten made in one
group d aid okay still I need to take
what down what else is there maybe in
special person what some of a liability
I know Knight f3 but Bishop g3 always
this one's just tempo and down if I get
to rid of this night yeah I was just
about to say that dumb if the night on f
2 moves at some point I have even 94 so
I could play 94 now should I yeah this
is just too tempting I need to oh wait
Knight f3 but I push up g3 okay yeah
well I just should just take this this
square here the monster you four square
and if he moves so let's say nite b4 now
attacking a 6 I can just take e 5 yeah
this looks quite good now our next move
will probably be Bishop g3 h4 to get
this back it's not so so bad on h2
really because it a taxi five but it's a
constant danger of getting trapped in
some way so I'm I wouldn't mind to get
this Bishop to I know back to e7 or
something I've won the pawn already so
unless I'm mum unless he tricks me or
something with the maid are some other
stupid truck I'm just running here with
the extra porn and it's basically it's
not just an extra porn it's basically
two again it's four against two here and
his majority is some it's just not
moving ok so maybe rook d7 could be a
good move here setting up a pin on the
night and activating the rookie are like
this can i play night before now yeah
this is some quite a nasty pin
uh-huh is there some at this looks this
looks oh I don't know looks shaky in a
way as if I have some kind of trick here
well maybe I don't but damn it does to
look shake him hmm yeah some may be a
good move I don't want to exchange
really this is such a strong piece
yeah I could play rock deform still on
yeah still keeping the the night only
for he plays let's say night be three
our job back to d5 and have improved the
rook position slightly it takes on e4 I
just take what the porn i should win
material takes on e4 fe9 tf2 I can take
f2 and the bishop is covering the rook
so I wouldn't have bishop he cannot take
I well I cannot move from mmm sorry much
yeah anyway if he lets me I'd like to
play King e7 and rook age 31 increasing
the pressure even more
yeah it doesn't have many moves really i
mean meaningful moves i'm not sure what
what you should do
yeah don't see move really which I mean
which really improves White's position
you can play stuff like night be 39 f 1
yeah this move I also thought about this
but this still doesn't threaten to take
and maybe I've got wait wait wait wait
wait maybe I even have Bishop Bishop H
form the ambush of age for looks good
intending Bishop to g5 getting him into
this pin hmm yeah maybe he can can take
the one a foreign play night f form yeah
it's not especially grateful for white
knight f form takes on 91 he's still not
threatening much flaking e7 let's play
king is him and telework the aid
yes so I don't see a meaningful move if
you move the d3 night in a way then
Bishop f4 once he takes on e4 I take
with the porn and this should should
really be a good also ok but this wait
wait wait wait maybe now now the bishop
to ya now I should try to get the Bishop
to g5 this looks really nice we place
Knight f3 looking like a fork then you
can play with shop g5 anyway he takes e4
pawn takes the ya Bishop g5 now and now
this ruckus at a penalty he needs to
take on g5 yeah and now I've got a dream
position here just transferred this
really black backbone on age 62 g5 and
now everything's working together nicely
yeah where should I go with the rook
there's some great idea just to be five
maybe yeah I'm not quite sure yeah
that's ok not before I was a bit
irritated about night before what really
i don't care much about the Queen side
if I'm able to let's say play rook h2g2
win this pawn then fng porn just win the
game I don't I don't really care much
about him taking any porn here on the
queenside is there something
especially great don't know okay let's
grab here first and yeah then simply the
checker on h 1 or 2 h 2 there's a
multitude of ideas i also have the the
very what is he thinking about i have
the the very simple move on night to see
5 which just was which is also very good
really just covering a six and he's got
0 plane after that absolutely nothing
yeah should i still give this check for
him so let's check first if you go
skinny too i can also play repair be one
and just pick up the be porn or force
them back to a passive in flight 93 but
still not see five is also really good
covering a six and maybe simply
intending to play stuff like f6 and then
push the pawns this is some worth much
more than than and then a simple extra
porn some strategically I'm really
terrible position for wide so um let's
just cover a six now play it simple and
the next move for might simply be f6 but
then I need to be bit cautious with 96
those checks might be M irritating
so okay give this check immediately so
just here
yummy it doesn't have a good scrub at
least one square wait what is doing
something naughty for maybe but still is
not attacking anything so on how to
improve now he might play before okay
but I have 94 all the time so maybe I
should um first draw the look back to e2
I think he needs to play to 32 now g2 is
just lost otherwise oops I thought them
I thought just 94 would win now all
right okay we can't play 92 some
terribly passive move so on what now
should I can i maybe even it once with
the King to t5 just um pick up pick up
the pawn wouldn't be a wouldn't be too
bad or just play for f6
okay I try to to grab the pawn I once so
wants to go with the c-4 okay yeah but
still I can grab it right I can just
take you five can I how does he defend
it don't don't see how pleasure cha cha
yeah this is checkmate checkmate this
was another neat little trick he
couldn't move the night because of the
mate yeah yeah i think is this whole
kind of play here with the drawing the
Queen exchange just leads to a quiet
quite fine position for black and at
some point here I don't think e5 is good
really why should maybe just cover you
form with rook e1 or night f2 and then
it's just the game the two bishops are
some some point where black can put his
hopes on but it's not like I'm
completely easy to to win on make a
decent progress why should just keep the
pawns on e4 and and f4 f5 is some simply
is it f5 SM is an idea more more like em
it's more of an idea that if I've really
FYI putting pressure on your six trying
to provoke like to play you five but i
think this I don't know maybe it's
technically still in fine but
but he needs to play and in some other
way then then indication I think that's
just just as Miss nice form for me he
could defend better of course just to
the plunder de-spawn but in general he
opened up the position for my bishops
and e5 as a weakness so I'm if he just
stays put here with dunno rookie one
that's not much happening yeah thanks
for watching